all right hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar automated gmp compliant
psc banking in a closed system
i'm isabelle and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laproots and brought to you
by miltani biotech to learn more visit
multanibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i would like to now welcome our speakers
ruffle crow principal investigator in
the research and development center at
cyrafon foundation and xiao xing product
manager for regenerative medicine at
miltoni biotech
ciao you may now begin your presentation
okay thanks a lot isabel for the nice
introduction and welcome everyone to our
webinar also from my side my name is
chaoshung and i am the global product
manager for the regenerative medicine
portfolio at milking biotech
today we are very glad to have dr rafa
crowe from sarah foundation with us and
he will present some his recent progress
on banking of gmp compliant human
proponents themselves
i know that his projects are still
ongoing so we are very happy to have
this opportunity today to already see
some of its most recent data and we are
also very happy that our technologies
especially the clean max prodigy cell
manufacturing platform
can support his projects on pse banking
well before dr crowe's presentation i
will first very quickly introduce you
our solutions for automated pc expansion
and differentiation as well as standard
flow cytometry qc analysis with our
widely used clean max prodigy so
manufacturing platform and the max quant
flow cytometry analyzer
while looking at the general steps of
psc applications
in particular regency medicine there are
many important requirements during the
manufacturing process for example it
needs to be gmp compliant scalable and
reproducible
meanwhile to make the final cell
products affordable to the patients and
also to the health care system the
manufacturing process also needs to be
very cost effective
so for all these reasons manufacturing
plcs and their derivatives for clinical
applications is such a challenging and
complex endeavor and
most of the current manufacturing
processes involve multiple very
expensive instruments very skilled very
experienced operators and high class
clean rooms and many
open and separated handling steps are
also introduced into these workflows
meanwhile standard in-process control
and quality control analysis are
required throughout the whole
manufacturing process
in addition in some applications
the desires of populations also needs to
be isolated in a styra gentle and
gnp-compliant environment
for so all these factors together could
really limit the manufacturing skill
compromise the reproducibility at the
same time
drive up the manufacturing cost
so how to make these very complex
manufacturing processes more
standardized more scalable at the same
time more affordable for the end users
well
here are the solutions from mutiny
biotech so with the climax prodigies on
manufacturing platform these separated
open handling steps these multiple
instruments devices the skilled
operators and high class clean rooms
they can be integrated into one
automated enclosed manufacturing system
and the users can also build customized
pc expansion and differentiation
processes on the climax prodigy
with the max quant analyzer standard in
in-process control and the quality
control assets can also be realized by
automated flow cytometry analysis
finally the max quant title source alter
can be applied to isolate the desired
cell populations with a very gentle fast
and gmp compliant cell sorting
technology
so now let's just
very quickly have a look at the hardware
features of the climax prodigy
well together with the gmp compliant
single-use tubing set the climax prodigy
allows automated self-processing from
starting materials to the final products
and upon your request it can automate
all these different cell handling steps
including cell sample preparation then
security and centrifugation cell washing
medium chains etc they can also all be
automated on climate prodigy
and in the adherence of culture process
the cell called division can actually
take place in two different units the
centrical unit or in the external
cultural vessels
first in the centricle unit so there's a
clean max prodigy chamber lies inside
and it supports automated adherent and
non-adherent cell cultures so you could
automate yourself feeding so harvesting
you can control the temperature and also
the concentrations of air and co2 we
also have a camera
integrated under the chamber so that you
could visualize your cell cultivation
and there are also multiple input port
are available for the cell cultures
so this climax prodigy chamber offers
100 square centimeter
100 square centimeter surface space
well if larger surface space is required
then the external culture vessels can
also be very easily connected to the
claymax prodigy tubing set via serial
welding for example these multi-layer
cell stacks so the users can actually
connect maximumly three of these five
layers of stacks at the same time and
with three five layers of sex then you
could have roughly ten thousand square
centimeter surface space for the cell
culture
well now i would like to shift your
attention to the attune cell culture
software
so when we designed this software i mean
our goal is to make sure that the
software is flexible enough to culture
different cell types so that is why we
modularize the individual cell handling
steps
so now you can see these different
different modules lies on the main menu
of the tunisia culture software so for
example we have the dense ingredient
centrifugation module the coating module
inoculation
culture medium change and the harvest
modules and the users can actually
freely select and combine these
different modules as a result very
complex workflows for example directed
differentiation of human proportions
themselves can be realized on the clinic
prodigy attunes our culture process very
precisely
and within each module the users can
also set up the cultivation parameters
according to their established sops for
example in the coding module the users
can set up the coding temperature the
coding time the volume of the coding
solutions all according to their
established sops
so these are the clean max prodigy
features
now also very quickly i want to
introduce you our standard flow
cytometry qc analysis
so for some manufacturing process we
know that requires stringent qc analysis
and the max quant analyzer is equipped
to meet the needs in regulated cell
manufacturing and this instrument offers
a lot of automated operational features
which could make your work not only
comfortable but also it can streamline
and standardize the workflows so from
startup to shutdown
this includes washing steps the max
quant analyzer takes on labeling and the
processing of the samples and
standardized initialization with
automated calibration or compensation
the accurate volumetric cell count can
also be performed on the sample itself
and does not require any addition of
further b
so to automate also the acquisition and
analysis of the ipc qc steps we also
offer several on-demand express modes
packages so these are algorithm-based
gating tools that can be added to the
max quantify software and allow for
unbiased and user-independent analysis
resulting in reproducible flow cytometry
data in addition if you need an express
mode for your specific qc application
then we can also customize the express
modes to your data analysis
and with the smart gain technology you
can perform multiple instrument
alignments for consistent and reliable
measurements from instruments to
instruments no matter of the operator or
where the instrument is located
in addition the software can also help
you with documentation so the max
quantify
21 cfr part 11 software dealer delivers
everything from audit trial to a good
user and role management system which is
necessary to validate the
system compliantly
so now i would just very quickly also
show you some of our results of pc
expansion and differentiation using the
climax prodigy and the max quant
analyzer
so we have established several workflows
for example the gmp compliant expansion
of human mesenchymal stromal cells and
human proportion stem cells
and also differentiation of human pscs
into main brain dominant progenitor
cells at the moment we are also working
on a new workflow to differentiate human
proportions themselves into
cardiomyocytes on the climate prodigy
and today we will focus on these two
workflows in the middle
so for pse expansion
we have developed the gmp compliant ipsc
blue gmp medium
in using this medium on the key
mechanology the users can choose and
combine already different modules to
automate all the complex handling steps
for example coating of the surface of
the surface pc inoculation medium change
pc splitting and harvesting etc on the
climax prodigy
so we also performed a
side by side comparisons between menu
and the climax prodigy based ps
expansion using the reaffinity
recombinant antibodies and the stemx
challenge differentiation kit
and looking at the expression levels of
these key proponency markers
and the trial lineage differentiation
potentials that we can see these two
groups the clean microprocessor versus
manual control
these two groups really give rise to
very comparable results
and then by using the centric code unit
and different sizes of the external
cultural vessels the users can also
easily reach different pse expansion
skills on the climax strategy
we we know that establishing tmp
compliant pc banks as a major steps
in many clinical applications and for
this purpose the closed and automated
climax prodigy attunes our culture
process together with the ipc blue gmp
medium and our standard qc regions these
could be really valuable assets for your
pc banking
projects not only the expansion the
climax prodigy at human cell culture
process can also realize very complex pc
differentiation processes for example
differentiation into
main principal energy progenitor cells
so we have collaborated with dr malin
palmer and dr agnet kirkby within the eu
neural stem cell repair consortium and
have already very successfully uh adapt
their very efficient manual
differentiation processes into our
closed and automated climax prodigy
so this is the process overview and here
i also want to show you some side by
side comparison between menu and the
climax prodigy
using the max quant analyzer again so
the results show that the cells
differentiated on the climax prodigy are
very comparable to the cells that
differentiated manually with more than
80 percent of the resulting cells
co-expressing the key mda progenitor
markers for c2 and otx2 and nearly no
expression of the unspecific or
proponency markers
in addition to the good differentiation
efficiency the climax prodigy also
offers automation as well as closed and
gmt compliant environment
meanwhile it is also scalable so in this
case we started with 1 million ipc's
and then after 5 days pre-expansion and
another 16 days differentiation we could
harvest roughly
to four billion md progenitors which can
be translated to roughly 600 to 800
potential patient doses considering 5
million cells per unit
and the users can also further scale it
up or scale it down according to their
technical request
so for the end users of the clay
microphotogy attention culture process
we also offer a very comprehensive
training program so this is a glance of
this training schedule so it is a three
days training program including
theoretical sessions guided and unguided
hands-on sessions and troubleshooting
sessions so it is very helpful for the
users to get familiarized with the
clingmac prodigy in fact dr crowe has
also participated in this training in
the past
yes the climax prodigy attunes our
culture process is still quite new but
there are already quite a number of labs
worldwide started to automate their psc
or msc workflows on it for example
professor
vanessa gosseli's lab from insurm in
france so in her presentation at ict
2020 she demonstrates that the climax
prodigy provides a safe standardized and
scalable manufacturing platform for gmt
ipc master cell banks
and this presentation is freely
available on our website
so today dr crowe will continue the
discussion on this very important topic
this is the disclaimer of my
presentation
okay so that's actually all from my site
so if you want to discuss any questions
in a separate meeting so you're welcome
to contact me via email thanks a lot for
your attention
now i would like to give the stage to dr
crowe to talk about his recent work on
gmp compliant pse banking at csira
foundation
thank you very much ciao and welcome
everyone my name is rafael krul and i am
a principal investigator at sarah
foundation's research and development
center
my presentation will consist of two
parts firstly i will introduce saira
foundation and talk a little about its
structure and goals
then i am going to summarize our
progress in process development from
for transitions from manual small scale
maintenance of ips cells onto automated
gmb compliant close culture system
sarah foundation an offshoot of kyoto
university's center for ips cell
research and application manages ips
cells manufacturing and quality control
and acts as a bridge for the transfer of
ips technology to industry
it was founded in september 2019 and has
been registered as a public interest in
comprehensive foundation on april 1st
2020.
after more than 10 years since the first
human ips cells were reported ips cell
technology it's being used to create new
medical therapies
syrah is involved in many projects aimed
at testing the safety and efficacy of
those therapies
the facility for ips cell therapy the
basis of the cyra foundation has been
responsible for managing the ips cell
stock project
manufacturing and quality control of ips
cells for clinical applications
the ips stock project has been
financially supported by the japanese
government and has received tremendous
assistance from the japanese red cross
society and the japan maro donner
program
as of april 2020 it consists of 27 ips
cell lines from seven donors the cells
have been used in clinical trials
managed by rican osaka university and
cyra
we provide services for academic and
industrial customers in cell
manufacturing quality assurance and
storage research and development
clinical application support training
and human resources development and
information sharing in industry
government academia network at the
national and international levels
the core of our philosophy is to provide
the best ips cell technology with
affordable price
in order to deliver medical care using
ips cells to the patients as quickly as
possible
we act as a go-between to bring
technologies
such as cell manufacturing and quality
assessment to the industrial world
our approach to ever evolving technology
is to strive every day for continuous
improvement
by integrating and sharing research and
development information we contribute to
clinical applications
improved quality and safety and cost
reduction of regenerative medicine
we continue to drive our public service
through strict appearance to ethical
standards
here it's a short timeline timeline of
sarah foundation's history
after discovery of ips cells by pressure
yamanaka center for ips cell research
and development was established at kyoto
university and cell processing center
facility for ips cell therapy was
completed in april 2010.
in august 2015 ips sales talk project
was launched
in february 2017 second cell processing
center fits 2 was completed at xyra
in april 2020 saira foundation has been
registered as a public interest in
compressed foundation
the central part of saira foundation is
facility for ips therapy consisting of
quality and manufacturing sections i am
affiliated with another unit research
and development center finally there are
two support units planning and
administrative departments
the representative director of sarah
foundation is professor shinya yamanaka
and executive director professor noel
kotakas
the term valley of death is often used
to describe the situation where
technologies and ideas developed at
universities and other academic
institutions do not successfully
transfer to the industry
universities and research institutions
usually do not have the effective tools
to put their ideas and discoveries to
practical use
in the u.s a bridge over the valley of
death is often made by venture companies
or large large investments but in japan
this kind of infrastructure is rare
the site of foundation is building a
bridge for regenerative medicine by
providing ips cells which require great
cost and advanced technology to
manufacture
free of charged non-profit institutions
at and at a low price for profit
institutions
now i would like to shortly describe our
ongoing projects
ips cell stock project is collecting
blood and generating ips cells from hla
homozygous donors because there is
increased chance of positive donor
recipient matching such cells
the stocked ips cells undergo strict
quality control are and are distributed
upon request to hospitals and research
centers for clinical applications
we estimate that the current ips cell
stock at feet could match 40 percent of
the japanese population
currently we have 27 lives prepared from
seven donors and some of these lines
have already been used in ips cell-based
clinical trials
to be able to provide therapies for
remaining 60 of japanese population and
also world population we started to
generate generate hla genome-edited ips
cell lines
they are designed to reduce the risk of
immune rejection by knocking out hla a b
c t 2 and retaining hlac
and e in order to escape t and
n-k-sub-mediated immunity
we estimated that only seven hla
genome-edited ips cell lines could cover
95 percent of the japanese population
and 12 cell lines could cover the entire
world
my ips is a project aimed at providing
an individual with their own ips cells
at a reasonable price
to make such therapies available for
large population syrah foundation is
developing technologies that will allow
manufacturing
of one owns ips cells at the cost of 1
million yen which is roughly 10 000 us
dollars by 2025
cyra foundation and its core facility
for ips cell therapy is responsible for
manufacturing and banking of clinical
grade induced pluripotent stem cells
it requires efficient and scalable cell
expansion protocols that allow for
maintenance of cell morphology
immunophenotype genetic stability and
pluripotency under current good
manufacturing practice requirements
we are currently working on the
transition from existing manual cell
expansion protocols in the imatrix 511
stem feed ak-03 and culture system onto
an automated closed culture platform
clinical
mac clinimax prodigy adherent cell
culture system that allows gmp compliant
and scalable ipsc cultivation
here we report the progress of the
process development the preliminary
requirement for the process was that
cells from existing stock are to be
initially expanded on the standard
six-well tissue culture plate due to the
low cell count in our existing stock and
to assure good cell quality
then harvested cells were to be
inoculated into the climax prodigy ts
732 being set chamber
cultured until under the adherent cell
culture process then harvested and
inoculated once more into the cell stack
one or cell stack five chamber from
corning before final harvest and banking
we hope that the process will allow for
the semi-automated expansion of
of ipscs from the 100 000
up to 500 million cells scale within
about two weeks
since the cell stack chambers are
available in several sizes that process
could be highly scalable and utilization
of automated system could greatly reduce
the workload of large-scale expansion of
ips cells
here's the summary of the plan based on
the multani biotic
protocol one hundred thousand cells from
the stock will be plated in one of one
well of six well plate then expanded
cells harvested and inoculated into the
prodigy chamber
passaged once into cell stack one or
five and finally harvested for banking
we hope to produce at least 60 million
cells from sales tax one and at least
300 million cells from cell step 5
within 12 to 15 days
from the next slide i will discuss
results of actual experiments
our standard ips culture system consists
of the imatrix 511 substrate at a
concentration of 0.25 microgram per
square centimeter applied to the vessel
without pre-coating and stem feed ak-03
and medium from ajinomoto
we usually plate one hundred thousand
cells in one well of six well plate and
are able to harvest around two million
cells on day five dissociating cells
with edta
the mitochond microphotograph depicts
usual
morphology before harvest
since ciao already introduced the
clinimax prodigy instrument and herren
cell culture software and workflow for
psc expansion in his presentation i will
concentrate on the protocol and omit
handling of the instrument
for the passage into the prodigy system
we recode
the 100 square centimeter chamber with
25 milliliter of
4.5 microgram per milliliter of imatrix
511 aiming at the chamber coating
concentration of 0.5 microgram per
square centimeter
this part had to be optimized since
coating efficiency of the prodigy
chamber differs from the standard
culture vessel and we needed to account
for some protein loss due to the
deposition on the tubing
after inoculation of 2 million cells on
day 5 we can harvest around 12 million
cells and proceed with the inoculation
of external vessel
the microphotograph shows representative
image of the prodigy chamber on day 2.
depending on desired scale of the
expansion we choose appropriate cell
stack when passaging cells into cell
stack 1 the 636 centimeter vessel
we use 100 milliliter of 3.5 micrograms
per meter of imatrix 511 without
pre-coating aiming at the coating
concentration of 0.25 microgram per
square centimeter
the yield on day 5 after inoculation of
2 million cells it's usually around 12
million cells
again the microphotograph shows
representative image of the culture on
day
four when cell stack 5 the
3180 square centimeter vessel is
selected for passage we use 500
milliliter of 4 microgram per meter of
imatrix 511 without recording
aiming at the coating concentration of
25 microgram per square centimeter
here we are still optimizing optimizing
harvest protocol
currently we are able to harvest around
400 million cells on day 5
after inoculation of 22 million cells
but to be able to recover all cells from
sales tax 5 harvest timing and
confluency need to be perfect
we believe that with optimal harvest
protocol we should be able to get at
least 600 million cells
the micro photograph shows
representative image of the culture on
day 4.
the poor quality of the image results
from the fact that the
to place the cell stack 5 on the
standard culture micro microscope stage
we need to remove the condenser unit
which results in suboptimal illumination
and lack of phase contrast
because we are still working on the
process we did not yet perform extensive
quality assessment of the cells expanded
in clinimax prodigy system
however when we return the cells to the
standard maintenance system they seem to
retain proper cell and colonies
morphology
to qc it's scheduled for after
completion of the
process protocol
i will finish my talk by short summary
clinimax prodigy adherent cell culture
platform allows for highly scalable ips
expansion in imatrix 511 stem fit ak-03
and culture system
transition from manual psc expansion
system to clinimax prodigy has its
challenges but they can be mitigated
without much difficulty
we are working on finalizing the process
and planning thorough quality assessment
of the cells expanded with clean max
prodigy platform
thank you very much for your attention i
think that now we will proceed to the qa
session
right thanks a lot ruffle and ciao for
your informative presentation so we will
now start the live q and a portion of
the webinar so if you have questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask question box located on
the far left of your screen and we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for
right so let's get started i can already
see the first question and this is
how difficult is it to adapt manual plc
expansion process into the automated
clinimex prodigy system
uh
okay so
well there are two main requirements for
successful transition from manual psc
expansion system to clinimax prodigy
platform culture protocol conversion and
handling of the instrument itself
we have experienced some challenges when
we started to use the clean max prodigy
system since it's a technology which is
very different for manual cell culture
but it does not like take a long time to
get familiar and comfortable with the
system
the big help was the clinimax prodigy
affair and cell culture system user
training an intensive three days program
held at midlaney university in
berges-latbach germany
that i have participated in before
commencing experiments
with regards to the culture protocol
optimism optimization
besides becoming comfortable with two
being bugs and other close culture
system accessories the main problem was
to adjust the culture substrate
concentration for optimal cell
attachment to the prodigy chamber which
took a few trials to get it right
the other smaller issue was scaling up
from our usual six well plates carried
to much larger larger surface of cell
stacks and adjusting seeding densities
okay many thanks raffle for the answer
the next question question is will the
clean max prodigy affect the propensity
properties of pfcs during the automated
expansion process
well maybe i think i can i can take this
question so because i think i already uh
very briefly showed some of our
results in my presentation well it is
indeed a very important question so as i
showed in the presentation so the pscs
that are expanded in the climax prodigy
attention cultural process well the
first they show very high they show the
expression levels of the key
proportionacy markers that are very
comparable to the cells that are
expanded manually
and second so the trial in the
differentiation potentials of the pses
that are expanded on the clean
microprocessor are also
comparable to the manual control
so um that's why we believe the quality
of the pscs that are expanded on the
prodigy
on the clinic prodigy they are you know
the qualities are very good
okay thanks ciao
and then we have the third question i
can see um it is can i use the clinimex
prodigy system to differentiate pscs
into other somatic cell types
um well i think i showed some results
from the mda and your progenitor
differentiation well you know
differentiation into other cell types
you may require
different medium small molecules
cytokines but as long as the you know
the differentiation process is adherent
and the handlings in the clay
microphotogy adherence cell culture
process might be similar thus you know
it's also likely that this can also be
adapted and realized on the clinic
prodigy but of course then we would need
to discuss more details and to to to see
even how to automate these required
processes on the clinic project so
that's why i mentioned if you are
interested in automating your uh process
in the closed climax prodigy pro
platform so just please get in contact
with us and we would be happy to discuss
further details with you and your team
in a dedicated meeting
many thanks
so it looks like that we have time for
one more question in today's webinar
and the last question is
how to connect the sales tax to the
clinimax prodigy and how to make sure
the connection is sterile
i think i take this this question
to connect corning cell stack to the
climax prodigy instrument uh we need
some additional accessories uh 33
millimeter filling cup with lower
connector from corning and one meter
tube extension from mildeni biotech
which also has lower connectors we
connect both accessories to the cell
stack inside the biosafety cabinet and
then the assembly is ready for
connecting with prodigy 2 being set by
tubing welder we are using thermal tscd2
that assures sterile connection of both
wet and dry tubing under the normal
condition
okay
thanks a lot uh raphael and xiao um so
do you have any final comments for for
our audience today
yeah yeah
sorry
i think go ahead
if anyone would like to have some uh
talk or or send an email exchange
around the
closed culture system or other sarah
foundation related issue please feel uh
free to email me or or find the
information on the cira foundation
website
yeah from my side i just once again i
want to thank dr rafa crowe for for
joining us today and presenting his most
recent data on uh human purpose and stem
cell banking so if you have any
questions please do not be hesitant to
contact us
and we also hope that our presentation
today could be helpful for your projects
thanks a lot
okay thank you again raphael and xiao
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank er
leprous and our sponsor miltoni biotek
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for the interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
so leprous will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so thanks a lot also
from my site and we see us next time
goodbye